the backlash against the social media
star who posted video of an apparent
suicide victim is intensifying despite
two apologies now and his latest Mia
culpa Logan Paul says he should have put
his camera down after finding a man's
body
Paul posted the controversial video on
his YouTube channel which has more than
15 million subscribers the 22 year old
is one of the most popular content
creators on YouTube
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn shows us how this episode
is also raising uncomfortable questions
for YouTube itself Vlad good morning
good morning well YouTube tells CBS this
morning their hearts go out to the
family of the man who appeared in Logan
Paul's video its guidelines prohibit
gory content posted in a shocking or
disrespectful manner but YouTube didn't
take the shocking footage down Paul did
it himself I should have never posted
the video Logan Paul appears humbled in
his newest apology nothing like the
young man who became a youtube sensation
by doing just about anything for laughs
I made a huge mistake
he's referring to this video he posted
on New Year's Eve which shows Paul and
his friends making their horrifying
discovery in Japan's so-called suicide
forest and literally probably just
happened after an outcry Paul deleted
the video but by then it had reportedly
been viewed more than six million times
in a statement YouTube said if a video
is graphic it can only remain on the
site when supported by appropriate
educational or documentary information
I've seen things I can't unsee the
company would not say what steps it took
during the more than 24 hours Paul's
video ran ad-free
there's definitely a double standard at
YouTube mic editor alexis Kleinman says
as one of the site's most popular
personalities are you excited it's not
in YouTube's interest to interfere
YouTube makes money through ads and they
will share that profit with the creator
Paul is the fifth highest paid YouTube
star making twelve and a half million
dollars according to Forbes magazine his
social media accounts reach more than 50
million people 56
and of his Instagram followers are 25 or
younger I think there's someone hanging
right there I think this has poisoned a
lot of people against him who were on
the fence but for his diehard fans
I believe that they'll go back to loving
him just the way they had before last
month
YouTube said it was adding more than
10,000 moderators after their site
received complaints over inappropriate
videos aimed at children CBS this
morning repeatedly asked YouTube weather
Paul's video had been flagged by other
users and whether YouTube had reviewed
the video before it took it down we did
not get a response and that is the issue
a lot of children are watching these
videos most of the audience for these
internet video stars are children and so
much material is being uploaded and just
not being looked at well insert
followers like this like my kids too you
know they follow these people all the
time they want to make it Alert and they
do they'd watch everything they do they
get an alert
I'm glad thanks